(audience applauding)
Please welcome,
Eric Stonestreet!
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)
How are you, Drew?
Good to see you.
Hello.
Hello!
It's good to see you too.
It's good to see you.
Want me over here?
Yes.
Sit, oh-
Do you wanna switch?
You have a lovely view.
What a wonderful view.
Oh, thank you.
Yes.
That's now like, the 15th time I've seen that clip
from "Domino Masters".
Oh, it's-
And I have to ask.
It looks so fun,
has there been a moment where somebody accidentally like,
set it off when it wasn't,
like, did someone screw up?
A hundred percent.
(audience laughs)
No!
A hundred percent.
People are out there like,
literally with tweezers, putting dominoes in spots
and there are accidents and mistakes and it all,
like five hours of work is just gone in second.
No!
Yes, yes.
Do people like scream and swear.
Yes.
And spit and like flip out?
I would turn into Linda Blair of "The Exorcist".
Yes!
I would pea soup.
I would-
It was all me.
It was me up there going,
"How much longer did we have to be here now?"
Like it was, it was crazy.
I think I have anxiety just knowing I would be the guy.
Oh, yes.
That would like,
hip check the table that was near one of the dominoes.
And then the whole thing like,
and I'd be standing there like the classic idiot
in the 1980s comedy like, "Oops".
Well, I'm gonna give you another thing
for your anxiety tonight.
Oh, please bring it on.
We shot at the Santa Monica airport.
Oh no.
Okay.
Where airplanes are landing
over the hanger.
Oh, no!
And then, I'm sorry, hello?
Have you heard of earthquakes?
So we would go home at night,
there'd be cameras rolling 24 hours a day on the stages,
and hope that an earthquake didn't happen
and knock the dominoes over.
(laughs) Oh, my God!
Yes.
All things I didn't think of
before I said yes to doing the show.
(audience laughing)
I love that, you know, you're from Kansas.
Kansas City, yes.
And that, you know-
(audience member shouts)
(audience laughs)
You grew up on a farm.
Yep.
And what was that life like?
Because it pays off, I think with Cam, for me.
Yeah.
Well, I grew up and I wanted a job when I was a kid
just like other kids kind of like, think to their parents.
What was your dream when you were a kid?
Well, I wanted when I was a young kid,
I wanted to be a a clown in the circus.
Which, I got to be a clown in the greatest circus
of all Hollywood, right?
(drew laughs)
Totally.
Hundred percent.
And then I wanted to be a prison administrator
at some point.
(audience laughs)
What happened that sparked that interest?
Because in Kansas City where I grew up, there are prisons.
It's known for Leavenworth,
the Federal Disciplinary Barracks for the army.
So I saw them as a kid and I was always intrigued.
And my dad was like, "But you're not going in one."
So, I went to college
and I wasn't a big fan of going to college,
but I found something that was interesting,
which was sociology.
And then that led me to wanting to be,
work in the correctional system.
The, they call it the penal system, don't laugh.
But that's-
Drew!
Penal.
(audience laughing)
So, I did a play in college and that redirected my life,
which I'm so thankful for.
Well, I love when
(audience applauding)
you speak about where you grew up and sort of,
having this mindset of bringing your character, Cam
on "Modern Family", into people's hearts and minds.
Can you tell me about that?
I wanted Cameron to be someone
that everyone would wanna sit down and have a beer with.
Yeah.
Right?
And the writers and the creators of the show
were very interested in my background.
The clowning, the drumming, the farming, the footballing,
all that stuff.
They wanted to bring that to the character,
to make Cameron a very well-rounded,
even though people look at,
some might look at it and say, "Well, that's a stereotype."
Cameron is the opposite of a stereotype.
And it's true to your life.
Right.
And it's all real things that, you know,
I wanted Cameron to be defined by something
other than the fact that he was a gay man.
I wanted him to be defined by that he was a dad.
I wanted him to be defined by that he was a parent
or a partner, who's turned out to be a husband.
I wanted him to be defined by that he was a football coach.
And that the fact that he was a gay man,
that Mitchell and Cam are gay men
is just part of who they are, not who they are.
(audience applauding)
I love that.
(upbeat music)